good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is Thursday this week is actually
sort of cruising by hey Claud at what's
good hey Jax it's good yes the week is
cruising by but like for what you know
like what are we rushing to nothing for
you and I I'm rushing towards a day
where I can sleep in completely like
past noon craziness I was just telling
you before the show I've been having so
much trouble falling asleep during
quarantine and there are many things
that like bother me but the one thing
that bothers me the most is not being
able to sleep and bed it's like fast
asleep next to me and like I'm on my
phone like it's so bright turn it off
like I hate being up I hate being like
left alone with my thoughts and
nothing's going on online like I it I
don't know what to do I'm on a bad
schedule I don't know how to get off of
it because I was up till 3:00 Reid I'm
not that bored but maybe soon maybe I'll
get there by the way if you really hate
reading it will put you to sleep that's
the point that's why I said it not
because I think it's gonna stimulate you
how do I read when Ben is asleep you
have to get a Kindle but or like with a
little flashlight or go into the living
room yeah I was thinking last night I'm
going into the living room and just
finally giving up and like maybe falling
asleep on the couch but I eventually
fell asleep it's just it's so
frustrating the nights are so long I
know I usually have a lot of trouble
falling asleep but yesterday due to my
shift in schedule where I woke up
earlier to work out and then get a
second workout with the live method I
think I tired myself out enough to fall
asleep around like 1:30 with ease um I
am so sore I did a one on one training
session with Matt from the live method
like in my room like literally what I
said I was never going to do you should
have seen me with my jumping jacks but
my whole second bedroom is now like I
have everything that I need Zach got
this kettlebell that's like digital and
it can become more or less weight you
just have to like set it it's crazy I
think it's the coolest thing ever
that is crazy wait speaking of the live
method there was a post yesterday in the
Facebook group like drop um something
you thought about the Steen's like that
ended up being not true when everyone
was like I thought Jackie and Claudia
were friends well blah it was just so
funny to see what like what people think
about us before they get to know us
literally everybody thought that our
sister Olivia owned the live method
honestly I
I can't believe more people don't think
that like it's so confusing no it's so
confusing and I'm sure people are
hearing this now and like they're
realizing that she doesn't own the live
method she started going there and it
happens to be called the live method
which is just it's I think that's why
she probably started like loving it so
much yeah it was really honestly a
hysterical post it was a great episode
for patreon for us to like react to all
the things people thought about us oh
yeah that would be really funny but
speaking of patron we're doing our zoom
happy hour today so such a busy day here
in quarantine our zoom account it's just
really getting its money worth jaci paid
for a premium zoom account and like
honestly that makes you like in this day
and age it makes you like a socialite
make a Rockefeller like I am zoom who
wants to hang I needed to buy it for the
redheads because usually they won't kick
you off after 45 minutes it's only two
people but we were four people and so
now I host every Saturday night zoom
every happy hour every you know Seder
honestly it's it's been a good
investment it's really nice to know
someone with the hook-up yeah and like
you know if you ever needed to use it
like I'd hook it up and you could borrow
and that just feels good to know like I
can fall back on that yeah for sure in a
in an unrelated story to my hole not
being able to fall asleep I'm getting a
new mattress tomorrow and I'm so excited
I mean Ben's mattress like I'm not gonna
lie when we bought it we definitely
cheaped out I just I want to say
mattress firm is nothing of the sort
because this bed is like less than two
years old and it is lump City and I went
with the finest mattress I could find
that would be able to live it to deliver
tempur-pedic tomorrow so I will keep
everyone updated I'm very excited for a
new bed I think maybe that'll shift my
entire schedule my entire perspective
that's an exciting quarantine update for
sure
I need something exciting like that oh
you know what I did yesterday I bought
some really cool nail colors from Essie
um from Target online and that's really
just gonna change things around because
when I've been watching Vanderpump rules
in real house
Beverly Hills now I'm envious of their
manicures
last night I was envious of gar Sal's
latte but envious of Erica's manicure
she had this Barbie too pink nail polish
on so I got four really cool summery
colors that I think are just gonna put a
little pep in my step I was envious of
their breakfast it looked so good we are
going to recap Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills you know they say less you
nail polish it like Duane Reade - yeah
they do but they don't have all the new
colors you know and I just wanted the I
wanted the whole collection I wanted to
choose my colors and the come by
Saturday
so hopefully fabulous fabulous fabulous
that like really is something new and
exciting for me you know what if
quarantine has taught me anything it's
truly just to appreciate the little
things in life yeah nuts and that's what
I'm doing and now that I'm like getting
pretty good at my nails I feel like even
after quarantine I'm going to utilize
this new skill not all the time but
don't you think there's so many times
when like you don't have time to get a
manicure but you're going to a kind of
an important dinner you don't want to
show up with chip nail polishing you
just like either panic or you show up
with chip nail polish that doesn't
happen for me anymore
that's very true something that I'm
taking out of quarantine that I have
learned that I would love to implement
in everyday life is cooking dinner I
just can't believe it like my whole life
well my adult life like with Ben we just
order dinner every night like it's
nothing and I first of all never realize
how much money I was spending like the
amount I would spend on like to take out
dinners is what I spent in groceries for
like the week it's very fulfilling to
like use your kitchen I can't explain
this it sounds so dumb to people and I
have a small kitchen and it literally
never occurred to me that it was small
but now that I'm using it so much I'm
like I need a six stove top you know
like I'm like there's all these things
that I need know I'm in the exact same
position I have such an appreciation for
cooking making my own food because I can
eat like better like more delicious food
because I can make it in a more healthy
way also my kitchen is tiny like we've
got him in and so yesterday me and Ben
ordered Chinese food and like now I know
the feeling like remember that scene
right before Charlotte and Harry break
up find out that they are getting a baby
from China she comes into the house and
she's like I'm a bad wife I picked up
Chinese and it's like I actually
understand that feeling now like I was
just being like a lazy wife but I had
been working so hard on my meals for the
last four weeks like I felt like I
deserved to order Chinese
worse I ordered a delicious feast as
well last night because I need some
protein I realized I've been eating all
carbs because I can't get protein right
now because there's no kosher meat and
I'm not like crazy about cooking fish
I'm not that good at it
so I ordered some kosher meatballs and
it was really good
oh that is good where'd you order from
what where's open PETA girl it was so
good yeah I'm definitely feeling like
this next week I will be leaning a
little bit more into taking out just
because I'm like over the stuff in my
house and I only know how to make like
four things so it's like a weekly
rotation of the same four things and
it's just getting like a little
monotonous yeah well maybe you could
check out some new recipes I'm sure the
toasters have great recipes I've been
loving getting people's recipes my
favorite thing to do is when someone
posts something delicious looking on
their Instagram story like a friend I
just messaged you my god this looks so
good can I have your recipe and
everyone's just sharing recipes some
people like my friends have been asking
me for my stuff for red pepper Rex
recipe so I take a picture of the home
chefs card and I send it to them um but
it's like a recipe change is a fabulous
thing
yeah but recipes are interesting because
in my journey I'm cooking I have now
followed three recipes from
foodnetwork.com and they were all a
piece of garbage like literal [ __ ] I
can't believe that the Food Network has
such like they should be ashamed of
themselves especially Giada De
Laurentiis because I made her Bolognese
and it was the definition of nothing of
the sort
so I agree I think getting a recipe from
a friend like someone who made it if
you're a toaster and you see here's the
thing I have very limited cooking skills
I have limited ingredients in my house
and I have a limited palette so like I
don't like things with vegetables I
don't like fancy things so like if you
have a recipe for me that it can be made
with chicken ground beef or ground
turkey or I have some steak actually um
and it's simple like a child would like
it and it's easy to make please tag me
in the Facebook group or something but
other than that I can't I can't be
bothered with you know a beef shrimp own
I'm glad you admitted that your bully
anis was nothing of the sort
and next time you want to pull your
knees recipe hit up Kristen because I
used her recipe and it was fabulous and
easy so easy but you know what I am
really good at that I'm not getting sick
of is making taco meat
I [ __ ] love tacos like and it's so
great the next day for lunch and I don't
know how we're at what planet I've been
living on that I haven't been eating my
tacos with Tostitos chips like then
them to the dinner table one time and
the salt you don't even need a show like
the salt of a casino chip dipped in your
like day-old taco me is yeah that's
really good I you know I know you're
crazy about tacos for me like I like
them here in there but I don't think I
could I don't think I would ever reuse
my ground meat which is so precious to
me now to make tacos like I'm always
gonna go meatballs or Bellinis yeah and
I just want to say one thing about
ground meat
those who say that ground turkey and
ground beef are interchangeable are
absolute liars like I think that ground
turkey should be banned it's the most
disgusting thing and I have so much my
house yeah I love ground turkey can I
have yours no I just in case I need it
but like it's discussing Wow see okay
well we've got a great show for you
today we've got passed out stories we do
have five and then we're gonna recap
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills and a
little bit of too hot to handle I just
want to like talk about some of the main
themes I'm seeing um because I'm only
I'm like Episode four but I'm really
enjoying it so far
ya know it's a fabulous show and I
really appreciate the minute the
episodes being under 40 minutes like
most of them are like in the 30s and
that just makes it so much easier to
watch like I really liked love his
blonde but there were so many episodes
and they were like over an hour and it
was just like a big undertaking and in
quarantine I'm on the mood for
undertakings oh I'm there like I'm in
the mood for undertakings and I didn't
even notice the episode lines because I
just do play next yeah you did like
really look at the lengths of things I
just yeah I like don't have a long
attention span no you don't well I don't
that's set on that are you waiting for
me to say something no okay I'm waiting
for you to say something okay without
further ado it's time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast um first story is an
exciting story it's a little quarantine
programming that I think is very in tune
with what's necessary sorry I was
getting all my toast phrases jumbled I'm
like pertinent to the necessary okay
Eddie Murphy and Adam Sandler joined the
star-studded feeding America comedy
livestream
Eddie Murphy is back on the stand-up
comedy circuit after a long break and
soon he'll be in your living room
the legendary comedian along with Adam
Sandler Chris Rock Tiffany Haddish
Howie Mandel Billy Crystal Kevin Hart
Marc Maron Marlon Wayans Margaret Cho
Tim Meadows Jon Lovitz and more have
joined the star-studded lineup of the
feeding America Comedy Festival which
was put together by Byron Allen a former
comedian producer and CEO of the Allen
Media Group the May 19th charity event
which is co-produced by Funny or Die
will involve the comedians performing
live stream sets from their own homes to
raise money for feeding America okay I
have two things to say one in that
lineup that you just announced there was
one woman like if that is not a stunning
indictment on the state of comedy
Margaret Cho and who else Tiffany
Haddish oh okay two women like my god
like they couldn't have asked me and two
I think this is fabulous like of all the
things that like celebrities have tried
to put together for us like that we
don't need this is not one of them a
comedians I think are like a separate
part of Hollywood we're like I'm not
feeling resentful towards them like to
me they they still are very much like
have firm grips in reality they haven't
become like Hollywood like Ellen's yet
so I think this is gonna be so funny um
I would love for Tracy Morgan to be
involved and I'm just unclear why he's
not well there's still some time for
some additions she's just like how Eddie
Murphy was just added also I'm so
excited for this because when I was
watching the oneworld um then on
Saturday night and like the Stevens and
the jimmies were hosting and I said to
Zach and they were like you know trying
their usual jokes but it just wasn't
hitting and I said to Zach like why
can't they get like an actual comedian
like Kevin Hart would make this funny
and it would you know not be cringy and
here we are like my prayers have been
answered
I'm so excited for this I think this is
exactly what we need right now yeah I'd
like to be honest when you said there
was like another programming
announcement I was like great more
blurry videos of people who don't how to
use cell phones like on cable but this
actually sounds fabulous and I'm really
I'm definitely going to watch it even
though I have a confession what I don't
think really crystals honey I'm like I
don't think I've ever
been privy to his work I don't know him
it's just like not my brand it's like so
old man comedy like I'm over it that's
fine it seems this is there's something
for everyone yes of course um I do think
that the programming though like we
started it like the I that I heart
living room concert to now where we're
at was like Disney family sing-along
like I think it's getting better for
sure so that's good
people are getting like better equipment
in their houses you like see I don't
know people who do TV shows they've got
the mics they've got cameras
teleprompters I feel like we're getting
somewhere we're definitely making
strides towards better Ness yeah but I
also feel thank you for that profound
statement I also am now like grateful
that we have actually a really good
remote podcasting situation set up and
now when you go on tour again like it
won't be such a cluster because we
finally protocols in place and I feel
like the world has really adjusted and
like lowered their bar for quality
content I agree with that thank you I
can I can understand what you're saying
it works yeah I could kind of see you
like the shapes of your nose and stuff
sure that works yeah so you see I on our
Instagram now um I'm no longer posting
like the zoom collage of us because it's
just nobody needs to see that absolutely
it's nice that anybody wants it so now
I'm just posting unseen photos of us
from this time last year where we were
glamorous and I just think that that's
more exciting where we at Coachella or
stagecoach this time last year we were
preparing for stage which I was looking
at my time hop and I had all my like
alpha Trion pictures so many outfits I'm
so glad I didn't wear like jelly but
then they totally hit I miss stagecoach
I don't like miss coach obviously
because that was total work but
stagecoach was those were the [ __ ]
hallelujah Knights and I don't know when
we're gonna have a hallelujah night
again we are having a hallelujah night
every time I had two white clothes last
night and listen to your corn students
playlist and I'm like known for making
plans when I'm drunker than like not
wanting to do that when I'm sober and
like I swear to myself I'm like now I'm
gonna wake up and want to do it and then
I don't but fire away came on and I just
like wanted to be like out of
fire at night like it doesn't have to be
warm like I wanted like a chilly night
bonfire where we're like looking up at
the sky
listening to music drinking Mayer and it
made me like actually depressed that is
all that I want is a fire bond candle or
otherwise care or otherwise like that is
fire on a trash bin oh my god sounds
fabulous okay next up Lady gaga unveils
the tracklist for her sixth studio album
chromatic ax featuring songs with ariana
grande Elton John and black pink okay
this is exciting even though it's not
really anything and if it happened not
in quarantine I would never choose this
as a story um yesterday you know it was
the most exciting thing that happened
all day because we got the tracklist for
her album she has some sweet collabs I'm
excited about all three of these I
actually think I'm most excited for the
black/pink collab I think that song is
gonna be the lames like everything um
I'm curious to see what her and Arie do
together exactly like they have such
different styles but I'm looking forward
to it nonetheless um I think I'm most
looking forward to Elton John's collab I
just think that's first of all so cool
for Lady Gaga and cool for Elton John I
think it's gonna be fabulous
the cover art was also released she's
like in a pink wig her legs look so long
she's wearing like her classic Gaga
heels it was very much like uh lg1
homage like she's definitely going back
to like dance club electric which I'm
totally here for but I was really
surprised at the comments on her
Instagram like so negative about the
it's the album cover like what's wrong
okay I hadn't seen the album cover until
just now I had seen the other picture
where she's like in um she's in that
like metal grate or whatever but now I'm
looking at the album cover it just it's
it's like you said it's lg1 like there's
no progression I feel but that's who she
is it's like she did all these things
and she decided like that's what she
wants to do yeah I just feel like it's
not it's not revolutionary and
everything that she does
Ezra's is revolutionary maybe she's
tired like she just can't see any great
boundaries she's constantly rebranding
she does art pop everybody hates because
it's too much so she scales back she
does Joanne it's not enough
even though it's the perfect album and
she's just like [ __ ] you all I am Who I
am here my here my claw hands and my
Alexander McQueen heels yeah like I
think she's tired and she's been like on
the circuit like Oscar Club bus another
club bus you know that tick tock sleep
Club another club bus club club another
club bus no sleep it's Lady Gaga I like
when she was in an interview talking
about it in her early days when she was
like doing clubs and they were like
what's it like she's like us Club
another bus club that's honey yes so I
just feel like she's over it like she's
been on she's just been doing the most
and absolutely nobody has been
appreciating it except for us well no I
don't think she's over it and I think
people appreciate it but I think she's
had this whole arc she's done it all she
did the Super Bowl she won like an Oscar
right for that song um and so now the
balls in her court and she's just doing
what she wants she's not worried about
like what she thinks people want from
her
but I think she also does know that
everyone will always be happy when we're
getting lg1 Fame monster born this way
vibes and so that's what she's serving
up on platter you know I'm I'm very
excited for it like that album Born This
Way like really defined an important
part of my life and I'm hoping that lg6
can do the same like I'm hoping I'm out
of quarantine by the time it comes out
and I could have like a fabulous summer
with it yeah I need a fabulous summer
with it like just supporting local
businesses and getting back out there in
a socially distant way because I just I
can't imagine like how we're gonna be
able to feel like comfortable you know
going out and stuff I don't even know
what like I think the thing I will
struggle with the most is like embracing
people like I already like think people
are gross and like will be limited with
like my hugs and stuff but now I'd have
like a good excuse I even like the
friends that I like like I just don't
know if I'll ever like hug and kiss them
like I used to yeah I mean I don't have
to like I've never worth hug me and
kissing them so that won't be a big
transition for me but it's just gonna
everyone's gonna have this awareness all
the time I feel it's not gonna be such
an easy transition for us like mentally
just to step out and like hit the scene
it's not gonna be like that it's not
gonna be like that which makes me sad
because as a girl who yes used to love
stepping
out hitting the scene it's gonna be
transitional it's gonna be transitional
but I look forward to supporting our
local businesses soon I'm really looking
forward to supporting the [ __ ] out of
them okay next up Julianne Hough is
talking about self ISIL self isolating
without her husband Brooks Laich she
said I'm really enjoying this time I
know you don't have time for this but
the story is everywhere her and her
husband are like there's something weird
happening they're not quarantine
together which tells you everything they
were they were and then they were being
like thirsty with the People magazine
articles now they're not and they're
being thirsty again with the People
magazine articles like I can't keep up I
don't even know who Brooks Laich is and
to be honest like I'm Julianne I was
like really making me hate her I know
she is
I know but you know what like I'm gonna
hold on a little bit more hope for her
because just cause like I really like
her that much and I I'm patient you know
I'm a patient little Stan julianne hough
is enjoying herself her time he's self
distancing amid coronavirus while her
husband Brooks Laich does the same in
Idaho she opened up about her experience
social distancing telling oprah magazine
she's really enjoying this time in her
life where she can connect to what's
really important in her life being on
tour for three months and traveling and
starting a business it's a lot so to be
able to be home and stop and pause and
look inward and connect back to myself
has been glorious I've been on my own
I just don't know does this journey end
with them just totally divorced and it
was the most drawn-out separation ever
or does it end with them back together
being like more well-rounded human
beings for having spent time apart also
to be care either way yeah I know I mean
I care because I actually loved her
wedding like aesthetically the lake like
I remember just looking at those photos
and being inspired like I just thought
it was beautiful I'm like jury percent
that was like my dream wedding and I
knew in no life would I ever have a
wedding like that cuz that's just like
not Who I am you know any where'd I get
this where would I get this farm we cut
back for this farm but the articles that
I've read say that like they're the
break in that relationship has to do
with like him exploring his sexuality um
which is good for him but like I feel
like he should have done that before um
I read um but again everyone's on their
own journey so I'm really like over this
I don't really care it's just so funny
when I think about Julianne Hough like
vacuum-like did I think she was gonna be
the celebrity with one of the most
dysfunctional dating like histories out
there no I didn't I didn't see that for
her but like that's what she's turning
into yeah the piece about him exploring
his sexuality is interesting cuz like
that's not mentioned in this article and
they're just like talking about social
distancing while he's like doing yard
work and she's in California and it's
like is he with someone exploring his
sexuality out there yeah and they were
very open about the sexuality thing cuz
I had read like a couple blinds about
him that were totally like unproven but
then like they were open they were doing
articles talking about how Brooks is
exploring his sexuality yeah it was
everywhere like I'm not making this up
no no no like I'm sure it's like the
first thing when you google him he also
has a podcast um
so I'm sure he talks about it but maybe
that's what's keeping him busy oh for
sure it keeps us busy yes it does except
we do it every day it like it always I
fail to realize that like most people
who podcast do it once a week you know
and that were actually not in the same
boat at all like what a gift imagine if
we just did it once a week though it was
a six hours long I know I wouldn't I
would not like that at all it's like
even the redheads it's not often enough
but now we're up to two a month so I'm
happy
this was my sneaky way of getting them
to do more episodes okay pandemic this
next story is crazy exciting a little
aviation news and innovation could one
silver lining according to my newsletter
could one silver lining of coronavirus
be the end of the dreaded middle seat in
coach United is the latest airline to
say it will start walking middle seats
in aircraft cabins as a way to give the
flying passengers more room apart one
airline seat manufacturer just
introduced new economy seating concepts
that could become the new way forward in
a post corona world they include a
middle seats that are flipped around
staggered seats and protected glass
shields around intead set headrest
okay I never had a Sega any reason
think this but now that you brought it
up like the airline industry is 100% to
blame for the spread of this pandemic
like the way that they heard people into
economy like their [ __ ] cattle having
no respect for their personal space like
the lack of oxygen like of course they
were involved there's no doubt in my
mind well I mean they were involved
because people like had to travel from
one country to another in order to
spread it so like Matt what they were
treating people who had the virus like
humans they would have affected one or
two people not everyone on the plane
yeah um like I agree it's not great
conditions but like it would have got
here they're not responsible for this
but um they're definitely like a
breeding ground for pee anyone who is
sick and this is what they get for not
treating us like human beings like the
way they just like shove us all in this
is a long time coming like the airline
industry as it stands right now is guru
is not it's so expensive and what you
get to be treated like an animal like
I'm just not interested like I'd rather
stay home and treat myself like a human
being so I think like their
revolutionising their way of doing
things it's time so if they're gonna
rotate the middle seat then the middle
seat is looking at the aisle and the
window in the row behind them the middle
seat is looking at the island um so the
the photo that I'm seeing now it's like
the mills I don't know I don't I
wouldn't mind looking at people as long
as out there not breathing on me yeah it
just doesn't see continued formula I'll
send you this article with some seating
arrangements they have some prototypes
because I think it could be instead of
three people three rows on each it can
be 2 2 2 2 2 I mean I've been saying
that for so long it seems so obvious to
aisle to aisle 2 that way there's no
middle seat there's only aisles and two
windows yeah I think it requires like a
little bit of a wider plane because
hanging of two aisles
um but okay oh yeah we need to hide it
up I'm curious on his thoughts yeah you
should send me this article ok fifth and
final story just news
I think is so crazy NFL is bracing for a
virtual draft amid the coronavirus
lockdown so tonight would have been the
NFL draft a big balls out spectacle in
Sin City and instead Roger Goodell will
be announcing picks from his basement
and our husbands will be watching like
with eyes wide open whereas I think this
can you imagine working your whole life
to get to the NFL like through college
with a scholarship you woke up every
morning 6 a.m. running suicides only to
be drafted to the NFL in a basement um
I don't think that you've worked that
hard for the actual draft like you work
that would be like you work that hard
for you know the games and the play and
they're gonna get that eventually but
like like your whole life like you try
to get to the NFL like the moment that
you get there it's usually this like
huge spectacle like people reference it
it's like the best day of their lives
like you're literally just like watching
a screen in someone's basement yeah I
mean that's just like the reality of
life now it's so crazy I think of all
the games that even like college
basketball players like they would have
had champions around Championships
around this time the March Madness
imagine working so hard for that and
then not even getting to play like in
your senior year in your like biggest
game ever yeah what what age do you
think is best to be right now like I
would not want to be a senior in high
school because like there are so many
things that are like so fun and it
really is like the best year of your
life I was joking with you like a few
weeks ago that I think if I could pick
any age to be right now I would want to
be a sophomore in high school like I
would probably love being at home I hate
school but actually like school is
really not that bad I think I think I'm
happy with the age that I'm at like
having a job like whatever your job is
like it's not that bad missing it
no I agree with that um I go back and
forth like on the one hand I kind of
want to be in third grade and I'm just
like no school this rocks um but then
I'm just probably like annoying everyone
around me
I'm trait I think actually right now is
a good time to be pregnant because when
you're pregnant like you have to miss a
lot of stuff and you know everyone's
going out and partying and you can't be
there and now it's like no one's doing
anything and so like you get these
months of pregnancy that
kind of like freebies because you're not
missing anything
yeah and so going off of that I have an
announcement
okay and I also think even though I
think it's must be so hard to have kids
in quarantine like little kids babies
toddlers they can't require your full
attention I can't eat like my hats go
off to those parents I do think like
this is an amazing time if you're a
working parent and like right now you're
home you are spending so much time with
like your newborn or your baby or your
toddler time that you would never get to
spend with them I think it's really like
a once-in-a-lifetime thing
and so even though I'm sure it is taxing
as hell I feel like it's a great time to
be a new parent and like get to see you
know your child grew up in front of your
eyes something that you might have
missed if you were working every day as
normal right like I mean I know someone
whose maternity leave like ended um last
week but we're not going back to work so
she's able to like spend time with her
newborn and honestly that's pretty
special yeah I was facetiming well when
I was doing my virtual training session
with Matt he is a he's a new dad and he
was just talking about he said getting
to see his like daughter grow up like
you know do new things every day develop
her personality he would have never
gotten to spend this amount of time with
her otherwise so I think that's pretty
cool so I must be quilty a new parent
right now you know and I know like I
specifically complained about quarantine
a lot but I actually don't mind it I've
gotten like really in a good rhythm like
I'm actually I feel like when it's time
to come out even though I'm I'm so
excited I feel like I'm not gonna know
what to do with myself and like there's
gonna be so much pressure but like stay
out all the time but like I love it here
you know and I've worked so hard like
every day cleaning scrubbing like to
make this place warm comfortable in like
a safe environment like I'm just gonna
leave yeah I also feel like people our
age we're actually probably even though
I'm sure other people look at it people
are eating like they're living the dream
they were drinking zoom in blah blah
blah I feel like we're the people making
the least out of our quarantine
situations you know ya know I'm
definitely like on the bottom of the
list of the world yeah I feel like also
people our age are getting a lot of dogs
right now and it's really also a great
time to get a new dog because you get to
spend all that time with them train them
which you would never get to do if you
were working so yeah like shelters
across the country being empty is like
literally the greatest thing to have
happened into the world let's dive into
our TV recap segment last night was the
second episode of Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills most of the housewives
were back in Beverly Hills it was just
another fabulous episode where my
distaste for Sutton's tract grew even
larger yeah okay so I want to start with
the first scene we see her and when she
goes to this super fancy restaurant with
Kyle was that not the most Awkward
dinner you've ever seen like their
conversation was so um just like stop
need and force and like um it sounded
like they were talking to be a zoom yeah
and sudden like you know and I forgot to
mention this last week the way that
Denis spoke to the the waiter at the
restaurant at their hotel like about the
corrupt Reposado like I really didn't
like that but she did just get like some
really bad news from Teddy and like I
was I was giving her a little bit of
leeway but like you learn a lot about a
person based on how they speak to
waiters waitresses like hotel concierge
like anyone so I really didn't like that
and I just felt like the way that Sutton
was like being still like playfully
condescending to the waiter like about
her drink like with the pale pink that
means less vodka more other stuff and
then like making him take the drink away
like it just gave me like a bad vibe
about her based off of the vibe that I
already had which is that she's like not
cool and she's condescending and she
like has money and apparently has a lot
of it and doesn't know how to act
because she was being an animal at her
own party and I'm just I'm really
getting a bad vibe yeah but I think she
you know not every housewife can be
perfect and it's like those moments
where one housewife is acting like
beyond strange and then the other ones
are like those are the best ones like
when she was dealing with the mayor of
West Hollywood who like didn't know her
name and that was so crazy and then era
country or looking at each other that
was hilarious so also I read some stuff
about Sutton so I think the deal is with
her she was meant to be a full-time cast
member they filmed him in her house with
her kids etc then some like legal stuff
um is going like with her contract was
going on with her husband because I
think of the amount that they could film
like about him or whatever
and so they needed to do some reshoots
for her stuff in order to make her like
at home package suitable for housewives
but they can't do reshoots right now so
they just um she didn't get you know
Dimond and she doesn't have a tag line
and that she was meant to and so she's
on every trip and she's getting the time
of every housewife but she just doesn't
have it cuz they couldn't like tie up
those loose ends because of quarantine
that's what I read so I wonder if she'll
be at the Reunion like permanently or
like she'll come on as a guest
hey it'll depend on her storyline in the
season but as it stands right now it
seems like the season it's all about
Denise I'm not like curious even thinks
about it makes sense because when she
sent two when they showed a picture of
her ex-husband his face was blurred out
which was very weird yes so I think they
couldn't get all their ducks in a row
there and then it became too late
yeah um so I just like wasn't liking her
like that conversation with the mayor
made me want to die and for someone
who's so she's just one of those people
in this sick of running feet Minh
housewife who talks so much about like
manners and elegance and all that stuff
but does things that are so ungraceful
like the way she was like oh you're the
mayor it's like this is your store
opening like be like that's not that's
not classy at all that's not southern
manners like that was real real tacky
yeah she says this like lack of self
awareness about her like as about her
personality that doesn't sit with me but
you never know like I'm gonna give her a
little bit more of a chance not everyone
can just be like perfect right off the
bat like our cell right and by the way
the little nugget that we got about gar
cells email husband thing like first of
all when she said her husband was having
an affair and then she said for five
years like my heart actually sank they
were married for nine like half of her
marriage was a [ __ ] Jam like I
totally understood why she went crazy
about that email and I think it was
totally justified and like [ __ ] her
husband and her new house said she's
moving into by herself is nicer than the
one she's currently living in so I was
just really happy for her but that was
like a crazy tidbit that I didn't know
no I didn't know it either and I'm sure
like we could Google and find out a
bunch of stuff I'm sure it was a huge
story at the time I like I just her
energy that she's coming in with is so
exciting I love that she's wants to be
set up because I feel like that will be
a really exciting storyline like all
these women have husbands who have
friends like let's get this girl
billionaire when Erica said I was like
yes yes
yes and the friendship like I see it's
just like real recognizing real and I
think the two of them are gonna become a
powerhouse and their conversation first
of all was everything like the fact that
Erica got choked out like she got choked
up twice in the episode and both times I
felt it was so earnest and like so
sincere when she was just talking about
her like everyone has something to say
about her marriage but like tom is the
best guy she's ever known she like took
in Erica's son when him and Erica first
got together and like it meant so much
to him and like everyone's just always
like even like he she didn't mean to be
weird book ourselves like what's her sex
life like and I'm sure it's like genuine
curiosity from people cuz she's married
to an 80 year old but like I love Tom
like I just love him and I love her and
I love the respect that she has for him
and people say so much about their
relationship like housewives fans but
like to me they're solid to me they're
salt like you could say what you want to
say about you know a 40 old woman and or
how old is she like 45 and he's 80 but
the fact is is what she said they've
been married for 20 years like you give
me 20 years of marriage with anyone and
I will respect it totally like she just
came out swinging last night especially
and her confessionals just defending her
man which is what I've been waiting for
so like I am here for it here for it
like if the two people at the lake house
from the deer toasters episode yesterday
are married for 20 years like uh mmm
respect we have no choice also when she
was in their kitchen and she gave her
lawyer a hey Tom the copy of the
Broadway agreement and she was just like
crying and he was like I'm so proud of
you he's coming out every two weeks like
we never get to see that like I saw her
on Broadway I did see her but I knew she
was here on Broadway I didn't even know
Tom was there but he was apparently
there every two weeks like I and she was
crying in the in the kitchen like I was
crying so hard like I thought that was
beautiful like from the Shakers to rod
way I feel like she's made the decision
this season to open up more with like
emotionally and also her house and her
life more um and it's really it's lovely
to watch because she's so well-rounded
because she's so fun and cool and Erica
and glamorous and fabulous but she's
also like solid as a rock you know she
has this just like constitution about
her where she's so moral and good and to
see every side of her is really nice
yeah and she was I'm locked up inside
with Megan McCain and I haven't really
been watching that much watched repins
live at home but I think I was wrong I
think I misjudged
because it was so good and so funny like
I was laughing like a normal episode and
first of all Megan McCain had such
interesting insight about Leah McSweeney
that I'll get to in a minute but they
did a segment um called what makes Erica
cry and and he was like asking her like
do you cry from like ASPCA commercials
and she was like yeah and and he was
like you cry from those videos of
soldiers coming home and surprising
their kids and she was like yeah and he
was like - you cry from like videos of
dogs on the internet like doing cute
things she said no it was really very
very funny and she was being like really
open she was being and she looked
sickening like literally her hair and
makeup was perfect do you think she had
glamour she did it herself she had like
her hair was too perfect literally I D
I'm trying like your [ __ ] hair she
said it was all her own hair I'm glad
you looked amazing it was very natural
like I just thought I don't know why I
was so taken with this luck and she was
wearing this like graffiti long-sleeve
shirt she looked like the best I'd ever
seen her especially the best I've seen
anyone on a zoom Wow okay I'm gonna
watch it then I have them all recorded
what did Megan McCain say about Leah
McSweeney
oh so Andy was getting like Megan's hot
takes that's how they like chant in all
the [ __ ] I love it
so he was getting like hot takes for
Megan I'm like all the housewife drama
in the franchise like what she thought
of New Jersey and then he was like what
do you think of the new New York
housewife Leah and Megan was like I
actually know her because she wrote this
like huge expose about the founders of
the women's March there was like this
huge expose done on them they're like
the three women who found it or the two
women were actually like closeted
anti-semites and there was like this
huge expose and Leah McSweeney wrote the
article about it oh my god it was
everything and he was shook like and he
was like what Oh Mike so Megan likes her
yeah Megan likes her Megan has like we
had I pretty much had like the same
takes as her she like was very she was
being really funny like she's like not
inherently like an effervescent person
and I think she talks about housewives
like the way she's on the view like
talking about like abortion so like she
was being so cutthroat like it was
actually such a good episode but then
they did the weirdest thing they played
this game and instead of Andy like
asking the questions they brought in
some guy he was like the 15th
Congressman of like a district in
California it was the most random thing
ever huh okay I'm gonna watch it today
so it was great you enjoy it I'll see
what you're talking about
okay back to Real Housewives then the
other big thing that happened was
Teddy's invitation to and tow reads
finances we need to talk about oh my god
okay we need to talk about that too but
let's just talk about Teddy really
quickly because it's like she just tries
to be chill and then it's like the least
chill text ever and then she's like okay
if you call him you don't come it's like
wait so you don't care if we come why
are we invited like yeah like I couldn't
tell if she actually just wanted the
women they're like because they're
filming they would have to go so if she
just invited them they would all go and
they would like we grudgingly be doing
the activities but at first when she
sent the text like you know what that's
actually really nice because if somebody
invited me to something like that like I
wouldn't want to go but if everyone was
going like I would feel pressure so the
way she said the text I thought at first
was nice but it was clear that she
didn't mean that like why was she being
so weird about this and then she just
like was hearing put in her mouth at
Sutton store opening so weird it's like
she doesn't know just how to be chill
and I feel like I feel like I could send
that text like listen I have this thing
going on like if you want to come come
if you don't want to come that's totally
fine and that would be it and no one
would like question if I feel like
there's something about her personality
where it's like we know for a fact that
she feels not like how she sent it was
just really like strange yeah and I
understand why she doesn't want the
women who aren't gonna like be into the
activities to come because like it'll
put her business like maybe in a
negative light like I totally get that
so I don't know why she just didn't like
stick with that mentality like if she
wanted people to come genuinely like she
should have just made everyone come but
if she really didn't care like what's
with the follow-up conversation it was
so weird it was so weird but we need to
talk about to reach finances because I
am so invested like her new house is so
nice like at first I was like looks just
like honestly for a second I thought it
looked like jaxa Brittany's house but
then when they showed it from the back
it's like a seven million dollar mansion
it's so nice and it's a theater like
it's obviously it's not as nice um
as the one that they were living in like
the one that they were living in JLo you
stone like it was a real Hollywood
Beverly Hills house and I don't know
where this new house is and
la real-estate but I'm sure there's a
difference there's a different you can
see the difference but also they were
renting that house and so you are always
able to if you're renting something like
you're able to get something nicer than
you would be afford to live in if you're
buying it but it's also just like
watching money down the toilet so at
first when I saw her house I was like
who's house is this like is this Beverly
Hills stone and then they showed it from
the back and when she described it as a
modern farmhouse and we saw all the like
um details I actually really loved it or
remind me a lot of Kristin Cavallari's
old house had Mary Cavallari um and I'm
into the new house I'm very into the new
house and the old house was kind of like
a joke cuz everyone knew they didn't own
it and it was like we're just waiting
and it's like I just it stressed it it
stressed me out I like the energy of
this new house for her yeah and you know
most houses in LA are like not unless
you're like an actual ability there you
can have like a very very fancy house
and the front looks like a Shack like
it's always like even Teddy's house but
that front it just looks like a house
before the back it's like a three-level
thing like that's like the vibe in LA so
I really actually do like her house I
just I want to believe that there's I
want to believe her that there's nothing
wrong with her finances but like I just
I don't know why so many people would be
saying so many things if there wasn't
like a little element of truth I want to
believe her that there's nothing going
on and you know what like I I feel like
I could have given her the benefit of
the doubt but like the producer sat them
down asked some very straightforward
questions and their answers sucked yeah
and like that's coming from someone who
wants to believe them and like they did
just buy a seven million dollar house
and also like if they're having all of
these troubles and they don't have money
in their con artists and now they've
been on TV for a few seasons like why
aren't they arrested yeah um also I
think that like the worst thing you can
do is when you're trying to like play
something off in someone asks you a
direct question because when the
producer was like why is the house in
your name and not in pk's and Jimmy was
like well it's your house in your name
where is it in your in your wife's name
like that is how I know you're lying
about something yeah it was just their
answer sucked in like they could have
done a better job and like now when they
were sitting there and the producer was
like you know fraud's Connor it's
probably I'm like looking at them I'm
like are these people are gonna be on
American greed next season like I it was
the first time I ever had any
doubts like and I've read the articles
but you know what things happen all the
time like with financial froze like
especially when you have legal troubles
like grete was having like we read about
the housewives Erika and Tom we're
having some drama Kyle and Mauricio like
I'm able to like push it to the side
because sometimes everything is fluid
and you know there's ups and downs but
last night's absolutely actually was the
first time I was like um but yeah and
you just know like Camille Grammer is
watching that episode and just like
living for it yeah I just they didn't do
themselves any favors like they had an
opportunity to explain you know and they
just they did a terrible job and even
their explanation about how like when PK
built this company two billion dollars
like it was just so fake no it no is I'm
sure that was amazing like when it
happened ten years ago but what have you
been doing since then and the fact that
that he was once running a company worth
two billion dollars actually doesn't
help him because it shows it like that's
the life he's used to living so like
even when he's not at that peak like
he's gonna do anything to live that life
I don't know but like that was their
explanation where they never finished
this story they're like he was running a
two billion dollar business and then
like there was no closure to that story
yeah I agree and maybe like that me and
out I want to give them a the benefit of
the doubt and say that the producers
maybe like want us to feel ambiguous
about it and see how things play out but
I also feel like in Beverly Hills they
do a good job of keeping the woman's
like this must have gotten to a point
where they couldn't ignore it anymore
you know like we never heard about Erica
and Tom's lawsuit or all that stuff that
goes down with the agency like they
don't talk about it but I like they felt
like they needed to talk about it and
that's what they left us with and I feel
like there's something there they want
us to know on that sad red carpet at
Sutton's store opening like with Tory
going through all that I don't even know
why she stopped and spoke to the
reporters like nobody else did yeah I
think that was one of Jarrett's best
looks ever so if I looked like that and
I were her I would have talked to every
single reporter take my picture write me
your magazine whatever it has takes
don't let this look go to waste on
watched weapons live they asked Megan
and Erica to rate derice style and they
both gave her a nine
in general yeah well Erica said she gave
her a 9 because only Erica's a 10 oh
that's cute but Dury is also attending
like I honestly I love that to read and
Erica have such different styles like
they're both a 10 out of 10 but I'm
completely like different sorts of vibes
oh sorry one last thing about Sutton
Kjar like mm-hmm she's just so been
erica was like it's obnoxious to say
that it's couture and it still doesn't
look good I just oh and you know I went
on bravotv.com and I watched Sutton's
home tour she honesty is a very similar
it's bigger and like not as modern but a
similar house layout to Jared's new
house it's like white and normal from
the front but then the back but you
could tell she's on like a bigger piece
of land it's like an older house it's
probably in a better area and the
decoration was like so sad there and I
couldn't take it oh wow okay I want to
watch Jack because I need some context
for this woman yeah I'm trying to figure
her out like I just can't
what's only Episode two like I don't
think we're supposed to have her figured
out that's why I'm not gonna rush to
make any judgments but I have Garcelle
figured out I know everything about her
she's fabulous she's everything of a
sort that's all there is to know I feel
like there's two types of people who go
onto reality TV like people who like
have like things holding them back like
skeletons in their closet almost and
then like ourselves just like diving
into it like she's an open book she like
on the second episode talked about what
was obviously like her biggest tragedy
and her life like her husband having an
affair and then that whole email thing
like I just feel like she's going about
it like totally the right way and I'm so
excited for her new house yeah
I'm excited to watch her story play out
let's talk about to how to handle really
quickly I don't think everyone has had
time to watch it I am not finished but I
just want to say like I'm so drian like
I'm obsessed with francesca and Haley
like I know there may be supposed to be
the villains but they're so funny like
everyone is being lame and also like I
started to think about this money thing
it's a hundred thousand dollars split
between at what was at first ten people
and now it's 11 people but let's even
start with the ten that means that if
you don't ever [ __ ] up you get $10,000
after taxes you get around I'm gonna say
$5,000 but now another person's coming
into a house we know later more people
come into the house
it's $5,000 when you boil it down a kiss
after taxes is about 150 dollars per
person so if I'm Francesca and I'm
taking a shower with Kells and he's not
kissing me and it's like I'm not worth
150 dollars so here's the thing about
the money and I'm not gonna I finished
it and have so many thoughts I'm not
gonna spoil anything for you but the
money they never make it clear what the
rules are in the beginning and only at
the end do you find out who gets the
money and how much they get it's very
ambiguous it's like at the end the
money's like irrelevant it's so weird
like it's this ambiguous thing and then
they only tell everyone at the end like
these kids didn't even know what they
were competing for oh my god that's so
crazy and also it's like they didn't
come on the show to win money like with
are you the one or other shows that are
contests like that like you go on the
show you know that if you follow the
rules like you will win the group wins a
million dollars you win about 35,000 but
when you're coming on the show just like
have sex on an island and people are
like you can have sex on the island or
you can get this money that you didn't
know was there and now there's all these
like weird rules with it and strings
attached like have sex I don't know it's
just that they wanted to really make it
in Tison they should have made it in a
million dollar pot because to get like
gold over $150 kiss if someone wanted to
kiss me for 150 to give up $150 I got
not worth $150 yeah the conversation
you're having you need to finish to in
order to really have like a because it's
so weird you'll say I don't want to
spoil it gets even worse like there's no
real incentive I mean they act like I
don't know it's just it's not adding up
also I agreed with your Instagram story
the narrator talks way too much they're
trying to make it like love island where
they have like a funny narrator and use
pop music and instead like this show has
it like a condescending narrator and use
yeah like license-free music um but I
like I like the some of the cast and I
like the set up so far but there's just
like something about it I mean I just
need to watch Mara and maybe it's just
cause the person that I like is like the
villain and nobody's nice to her yeah
you'll see but with the narrator like I
actually like not having like a Nick and
Vanessa Lachey like I like just
they cut time like the episodes are
really concise like I like that but the
girl chimes in way too much and for
every five jokes she has one of them
it's funny like the rest are so
condescending she's just always making
fun of everyone's intelligence like I am
NOT into the narrator I need like fifty
percent less narrator um and I like the
concept of like remote like Lana and I
read an article they only had five
cameras on like camera men or women on
the actual retreat the other scenes were
filmed like from remote um like security
camera basically so it was really was
like they left them alone there was no
host and I liked that but at some points
like lana was talking so [ __ ]
slow like especially towards the end
when she's telling me who won she goes
and okay we like that so I'm gonna watch
that today um who do you like and then
when we cut it okay so I really like for
the girls I love Fran and Haley I love
their friendship they're hilarious and
they kissed and then they were like that
was the best time I ever had in this
whole house with these people that I
hate I was laughing so hard um the two
British girl not there's Chloe is fine I
know you don't like her but so far she's
just like funny and silly and she said I
actually like all the girls I like
Rhonda - I think she is such a good head
on her shoulders and she's making smart
choices like her and Shirin obviously at
the connection but like if he's not
gonna be emotional the elbow towards her
she's gonna explore her options which
led her to dated who I actually think is
the most eligible man on that beach like
he's just so in tune with himself and
he's so good-looking and nice and um but
then ultimately like Rhonda and sharona
are super cute together and I mean she
like feels more towards him and right
now they just got back together on the
beach in like the most beautiful scene
I've ever seen in my life um and then I
hate Harry like I think he's such a
loser he is he's just so immature they
don't tell you their ages by the way but
I'm totally do you know that Chloe
I was because I couldn't sleep last
night I was going on a major thing Chloe
just turned 21 did this was filmed in
2019 I believe she was 19 years old when
they were filming it oh my god that's
crazy so I think Harry's also 19 years
old but here in Jessica's like way too
mature for him actually liked her in cow
but um I don't think they actually like
have any sort of emotional connection
what other guys are there oh then the
new Byron Bryce he is all like are you
like I thought he was gonna show up with
his like closest thing to a dad bad we
see on that beach and and I thought he
was gonna like you know be sweet and
said it's like a new girl every night
and next morning I'm like get out of
here I need a new girl yeah and his boat
like it's just so funny because to be
honest like I Haley was like he lives on
a boat I don't know what that means he's
rich or he's broke I was like true so
true I mean it's just so funny because I
finish in like I honestly felt the exact
same way about almost everyone except I
immediately hated Chloe and she gets so
much worse like you're literally gonna
hate her um I felt the same way but now
it's like some of the people like really
dive into like the personal growth
element it like some people don't um and
it makes you like like and dislike
people in certain ways so you'll finish
it tomorrow and we'll recap it and we're
working on getting some of the
contestants joining us remotely next
week so stay tuned for that
yeah and that's our show anything else
want to say before I wrap up no um we
have to do our zoom happy hour today I'm
so excited I'm gonna get questions in
toast after dark so if you are
interested in that head to patreon.com
slash the morning toast lots of premium
content to help get you through the
queue we are so grateful to everyone who
is watching and enjoying these zoom
recordings and we're grateful to all the
essential workers out there and health
care workers and everyone who is helping
keep our people and the world safe and
healthy and happy thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast and
Monday morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
heard of Cass bucks all the places
whoever you listen to podcast finest
morning toast I leave a five-star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are also please follow us on
Instagram at the morning trust me we'll
see you guys tomorrow Friday bye